IS A MUSICAL >> Dana: A
"NEW YORK TIMES" BOMBSHELL ABOUT
BRETT KAVANAUGH
FORCED TO MAKE A MAJOR REVISION.
FRIENDS SAY SHE DOESN'T EVEN
RECALL THE ALLEGED INCIDENT.
DEMANDING THAT KAVANAUGH BE
IMPEACHED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDING.
>> I THINK "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
MADE ANOTHER TERRIBLE MISTAKE.
IT'S A SHAME THAT A THING LIKE
THAT COULD HAPPEN.
I THINK THEY ARE MAKING A BAKE
CORRECTION TODAY.
I HAVE JUST ANNOUNCED THE
CORRECTION.
IT'S A TERRIBLE THING.
IT'S A FALSE ACCUSATION.
WHATEVER HAPPENED WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
I MEAN, I CAN TELL YOU
PERSONALLY, THEY NEVER CHECKED.
WE USED TO HAVE A THING CALLED
FACT-CHECKING.
THEY DON'T DO FACT-CHECKING
ANYMORE.
THEY USE TO CALL AND SAY, "WHAT
ABOUT THIS.
WHAT ABOUT THAT?"
HOW CAN THEY DO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT?
I MEAN, THEY ARE DESTROYING
LIVES.
IT'S FAKE NEWS.
FAKE NEWS.
BUT IT'S A VERY FAIR QUESTION.
THEY HAVE TO BE VERY
EMBARRASSED.
BUT MUCH MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHAT
THEY DO IS WRONG, AND THEY DO IT
ALL THE TIME.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, GREG.
STAY WHEN I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T SEE THE PROBLEM HERE.
THEY JUST LEFT OUT ONE MINOR
DETAIL.
RIGHT?
IT'S LIKE, IMAGINE A FRONT PAGE
THAT SAYS "MAJOR STOCK MARKET
CRASH."
AND THEN IT SAYS, "WELL,
ACTUALLY, THE STOCK MARKET IS U
UP.
"MOST WRITERS ARE LIBERAL.
BUT MOST GOOD EDITORS WILL
OPERATE WITH A CONSERVATIVE
FILTER SO THEY DON'T GET
COMPROMISED BY THEIR OWN BIASES.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY ARE LIBERAL,
BUT IF THEY DON'T CHECK
THEMSELVES, THEN THEY MIGHT
ALLOW A CORRUPT PRODUCT TO GO
THROUGH.
THAT NO LONGER EXISTS FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
ANYTHING GOES THROUGH.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE PRETTY
GRATEFUL THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
LIKE MOLLIE HEMINGWAY THAT ARE
OUT THERE.
BECAUSE I DIDN'T SPEND THE TIME
THIS WEEKEND READING A BOOK.
I DIDN'T SPEND THE TIME CHASING
DOWN THIS.
BUT IF ONE PERSON OR TWO PEOPLE
WEREN'T PAYING ATTENTION THAT
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY HADN'T PUT IN D
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY HADN'T PUT IN M
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY HADN'T PUT IN N
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY HADN'T PUT IN C
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY HADN'T PUT IN P
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY HADN'T PUT IN I
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY HADN'T PUT IN T
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY HADN'T PUT IN D
THIS OUT, THE COPS WERE NOT
ACCOSTED.
THEY ARE ONLY DOING IT BECAUSE
THEY GOT CAUGHT.
IT RAISES A REALLY BIG QUESTION,
HOW MANY STORIES DID THEY GET
AWAY WITH BECAUSE NOBODY WAS
PAYING ATTENTION?
I WOULD SAY ALMOST ALL OF THE
STORIES "NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
DONE ARE INACCURATE AND WRONG.
THAT'S HOW I SEE IT.
NOW, THEY'RE ALL WRONG.
YOU KNOW THIS, DANA.
JUAN, YOU KNOW THIS.
WHEN YOU BECOME AN OBJECT OF A
STORY, THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW
STUFF IS LEFT OUT.
IT'S TRUE.
STAY FOR IT'S FAIR TO SAY
EVERYTHING THEY RIGHT --
>> Greg: THEY WROTE STUFF
ABOUT ME YEARS AGO, AND I JUST
KIND OF LAUGHED IT UP, BECAUSE I
WAS LIKE, "WELL, YOU CAN'T GET
ALL RIGHT HERE IT" >> Jesse:
THEY ACTUALLY DID A STORY ON ME
AND THEY PUT THE WRONG PERSON'S
PICTURE.
>> Dana: BUT DID IT WORK IN
YOUR FAVOR?
>> Jesse: EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT
I LOOK LIKE, UNFORTUNATELY.
BUT I DO AGREE WITH YOU, GREG.
HERE'S WHERE I DISAGREE WITH
YOU.
I THINK THEY MADE THE MISTAKE ON
PURPOSE.
I THINK THEY LEFT THIS OUT AND
THEN THE DAY LATER, THEY SAID,
," WILL PUT THAT IN THERE."
THEIR AGENDA RIGHT NOW IS TO
SELL NEWSPAPERS AND ATTACKED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I DIGEST THESE MEDIA ATTACKS.
JUAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO HEAR?
>> Jesse: I'D WAIT 24 HOURS
AND ON THE BOMBSHELL COMES OUT.
WE'VE HAD THE STORY.
WE'VE HAD THE CNN-RUSSIA STORY.
AND THEN, WITHOUT THE TRUMP
STORY.
ALL OF THOSE TURNED OUT TO BE
NOT WHAT THEY WERE PRESENTED AS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
>> Greg: "THE NEW YORK TIMES" ."
THEY EXPAND.
IN THIS CASE, THEY EXPAND AND
THEN THEY SHRINK.
>> Dana: YEAH, THE 80s.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: OKAY, ANYWAY.
EVEN JOE CRITICIZED
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HERE.
THERE WERE NO COLLABORATORS.
THE ONE WOMAN WHO SAID THAT SHE
WAS THERE, SHE SAYS SHE WASN'T
THERE.
THIS WAS INVESTIGATED BY THE
SENATE, INVESTIGATED BY THE FBI.
THIS NEW STORY.
THINK ABOUT HOW RIDICULOUS THIS
SOUNDS.
HE HAD SOMETHING OUT AT A PARTY
AND SOMEONE PUSHED THE [BLEEP]
INTO SOMEONE ELSE.
THERE IS NO WITNESSES AND THE
ONE PERSON WHO HEARD ABOUT IT
WORKED AS A DEFENSE LAWYER.
I MEAN, COME ON.
IT'S PREPOSTEROUS.
THIS JUST SHOWS HOW BANKRUPT THE
LEFT IS.
ALL THEY DO IS THEY SMEAR
AGAINST RACISM.
THEY SMEAR AGAINST RUSSIA.
THEY SMEAR AGAINST [BLEEP].
JUAN I DON'T THINK THIS IS ABOUT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
IN MY MIND, THIS IS ABOUT THE
FBI AND THE SENATE.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY, DURING THOSE
HEARINGS, NOW, A YEAR AGO, DANA,
WE WERE PROMISED ONE KAVANAUGH
WAS CONFIRMED, THAT THE FBI
LOOKED INTO THIS, AND THAT THERE
WAS NOTHING THAT YOU COULD NOT
REFUTE WHAT JUSTICE KAVANAUGH
HAD SAID, AND IT WOULD BE UNFAIR
TO HIM, UNFAIR TO ANYBODY TO
JUST ALLOW THESE ALLEGATIONS TO
STAND.
AND THE FBI COULDN'T FIND
ANYTHING TO BACK UP WHAT HE WAS
SAYING.
ACTUALLY, SHE GAVE A GOOD
TESTIMONY.
BUT NOW, WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS
NOT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SENATOR COONS
SAYING THAT HE SENT THEM A
LETTER OF THE ALLEGATIONS.
AND THE ALLEGATIONS STILL STAND,
BY THE WAY, OF THE MAN WHO
ATTENDED YALE WITH KAVANAUGH.
PARTNERSHIP.
A NONPARTISAN GROUP.
BUT HE IS THE ONE WHO MADE THIS
ALLEGATION BACK THEN.
SENATOR COONS SAID HE SENT THIS
ALLEGATION TO THE FBI.
BUT THE FBI APPARENTLY DID NOT
INVESTIGATED.
>> Dana: HOW DO YOU
INVESTIGATE WHEN THIS GUY SAYS
THIS HAPPENED TO THIS WOMAN.
>> Greg: THE ALLEGATIONS WERE
SEEN AS VERY FLIMSY.
ALL OF THEM HEARD IT FROM EACH
OTHER SECONDHAND.
>> Juan: THE BUT THE POINT IS,
IF YOU HAD INVESTIGATION, WE
WOULD KNOW, IT COMES OUT IN THIS
BOOK, BY THE WAY, THAT THE
"LOS ANGELES TIMES" REPORTER HAS
A SIMILAR THING GOING.
AND THE PEOPLE SAY --
>> Greg: YOU, THEY HEARD FROM
EACH OTHER.
>> Juan: AND, MATT DYER IS
SAYING, YET WE HEARD IT.
THEY OMITTED KEY INFORMATION
THAT THIS WOMAN HAS DECLINED TO
BE INTERVIEWED AND SAYS TO HER
FRIENDS THAT SHE DOESN'T
REMEMBER.
>> Dana: BUT IF THAT'S THE
CASE, HOW DO THEY INVESTIGATE
SOMETHING THAT THE WOMAN DOESN'T
EVEN KNOW IF IT HAPPENED.
OR HOW DO YOU SAY THAT THE
INVESTIGATION IS NOW COMPLETE
BECAUSE THERE IS NO COOPERATING
EVIDENCE?
THAT DOES NOT A COOPERATION
MAKE.
MY ISSUE WITH THIS IS THAT
YOU'VE SAID THAT THERE IS THE
NEWS ASPECT, THERE'S THE
PUBLICATION, AND THEN, THERE'S
THE DELIVERY.
HOW MANY TWEETS HAVE THEY HAD TO
DELETE LATELY?
SO THEY PUBLISHED AND OMITTED
NOT JUST KEY INFORMATION, BUT
LITERALLY FUNDAMENTAL
INFORMATION.
THIS IS LIKE IN THE 40s OR
50s WHEN THEY WERE
BROADCASTING WAR OF THE WORLDS
ON THE RADIO.
THEY DIDN'T SAY THAT THIS WAS
FICTION.
PEOPLE WERE FREAKING OUT THAT
PEOPLE WERE ATTACKING THEM.
SO, THEY OMIT THE FUNDAMENTAL
INFORMATION THAT THIS IS NOT
COLLABORATED
COOPERATED.
AND THEN, WE HAVE ON THE SIDE A
BUNCH OF 2020 DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES, WHO SAY THEY ARE ALL
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND
YET OUR PLAYING.
IF THEY CONTINUE TO PURSUE
THIS, THEY ARE SHOOTING
THEMSELVES IN THE FOOT, AND THEN
IT IS THEMSELVES THAT THEY ARE
DESTROYING.
STAY FOR A WHILE, I DON'T THINK
IT IS RECKLESS, AS YOU SAY,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THEY HAVE A GUY A MAX THE RECORD
SAYING --
HOLD ON.
DEBORAH RAMIREZ MADE A SIMILAR
ALLEGATION DURING THE COURSE OF
THE HEARING.
NOW, WE'RE THINKING, HEY, THIS
SOUNDS A LOT LIKE WE WERE
HEARING BEFORE AND THE OTHER